so the week after the Fourth of July is
the busiest in animal shelters all
across the county here is no exception
hundreds of animals run away and most of
them will never make it back home a
NewsHour reporter Victoria Saha tells us
what you can do if you find a lost pet
and how animal groups are working to
reunite pets and owners
it's a busy day for the animal
foundation as they're expecting lots of
lost animals to come in after the 4th of
July weekend but they can't take in all
the animals so they're trying to make it
as easy as possible for you to help it
reunite with its owner they're offering
food water bowls and even toys
fireworks may be pretty to see but
they're scary sounds for your pets Ivory
Rollins found peso a female bulldog it's
too hot for these dogs to be stranded
walking around the water pesos
microchipped but there wasn't an odor
registered to it making it difficult to
return her are you ready to go home
the animal foundation takes in hundreds
of lost pets during the 4th of July but
intake is limited this year so they set
up a tent for finders like Rollins to
get supplies money is really tight so to
get dog food water the accessories and
things like that that's perfect Allison
Ford with the animal foundation says
this time last year they took in more
than
577 animals only 124 were reunited with
their owners if they're not microchipped
and people don't know to look at the
shelter then chances are that they're
not always going to be reunited with
their families
for rescues like the doggy task force it
was a busy night I didn't get to sleep
until about 4 a.m Kelly Winder says they
had a team of 10 people throughout the
valley looking for Animals running from
fireworks dogs running down streets
there was deceased dogs last night as
well they came across almost a dozen
dogs who were reunited or are currently
with a temporary foster but there could
be many more out there Victoria Saha 8
News Now
so this is tough definitely a tough
situation to be in so if you're looking
to return a dog that you found the
foundation is only accepting them on a
case-by-case basis because the next
available appointment to surrender a dog
isn't until August 11th now if you lost
a dog just scour the lost and found
section of their website check the next
door app check social media now if you
found a dog have it scanned for a chip
then maybe just try walking it around in
your neighborhood chances are they're
not too far away from home Brian